みなさんこんにちは
えっと先ほどのこのヘッドセットがあの後ろに付いててあのメガネを絶対かけようと
思ってきたんですけどちょっと浮いてるんで
途中で落ちたとしてもまあご愛嬌だとして許してください
a 棟
みなさん突然ですがコラボレーションとは何だと思いますか
先ほどのマジックにかぶせるわけではないんですがコラボレーションとは自分のほしい
未来をつくるマジックだと思います
みんなそれぞれ違った際のスキル経験を持っています
そんな
たくさんのものが重なり合うことで大きな可能性が広がる
どんどんどんどん大きなものに挑戦するチャンスが訪れると思っています
僕は
一人では何もすることができない1人でいろんなことを達成することができない
そんなスーパーパワーを持った人間でもありません
しかし
世界をアッと驚かせる世界を変えてやる
そんなことにどんどんどんどん挑戦をしていきたいという野心があります
そのために僕が取れる手段はコラボレーションでした
どんどんどんどん大きなものに挑戦すること
達成するためにコラボレーションを作ると言い彼と生き方をしています
コラボレーションを作るとはそんなに難しいことではありません
まず人に会い話を聞きつながりの可能性を見出しながら一個一個着実に実践実践
アクションに起こしていく
まず人に会うことでたくさんの可能性が広がると思います
一人では思いつかなかったようなアイディア
1人では到底達成するような達成することができないような大きな仕事
そのようなことに挑戦するチャンスがコラボレーションを作ることでどんどんどんどん
生まれてきます
最初にも言いましたが僕は本当に作用がありません
必死で取り組んだ部活動本気であった受験勉強
憧れだった代イギリス大学院留学そしてイギリスロンドンで立ち上げた社会起業
そのどれも必死であった自信はありますがどれも成功はしませんでした
重厚6年間全国大会を目標にハンドボールでものに打ち込みました
しかし結局全国大会に行くことができませんでした
皮脂で受験勉強して東京の大学を目指しましたが
第5第一志望の大学にわかりませんでした
そして
憧れていたイギリス大学院留学は憧れの建築家が教鞭を振るう大学院
行きたいと思い必死に勉強もし必死で英語を勉強しましたが結果は結局不合格でした
そしてイギリスロンドンで立ち上げ滝会社も約半年で
実測をしていきました
特に人生をかけて行ったイギリスの会社が誰の目にも留まらず
立ち上げたサービスの静かに無視されてこの状況は
さすがに答えました
その時
自分って何ができるんだろう本当に自分って何もできない人間なのかな
さすがに思えないました
しかし大丈夫に最初にも言ったように僕には野心がありました
何もできないけどとにかく大きなことをやって世界をあっと驚かしたい
とにかく大胆にしていきたいそういう思いがありました
なので今僕の身の回りにた起業家の人たちもうすでに大胆に生きている人たち
その人たちがどうやって始めたのかなんで今やってるのかっていうのをちょっと
インタビューしてもありました
そこで返ってきた答えはとても意外なものでした
仲間がいたからねぇ
1人だ絶対やってないよ1人は絶対達成もしれない
そう友達が人メンバーになってくれたり友達が応援をしてくれたり
彼らにはそういう仲間がいたから自分を始めたんだと自信を持って行っていました
当時切磋琢磨をしていたが切磋琢磨をしていた
起業家たちも今自信を持って自分のビジネス自分のプロジェクト自分の企画というもの
をやっていますが根底では到底一人ではやっていない
到底一人がこんなことはできないと思っていると言っていました
そこで僕は自分のほしい未来をつくること自分のやりたいことをやるために必要なのは
決してスキルや才能だけではなく
仲間の存在がもっともっと重要なんだということに気づかされました
それから僕はソーシャルキャピタル人のつながりというものに没頭していくことになり
ました
それから一心不乱にコラボレーションを作り続けました
まずは一緒にフラットをシェアしていた友人とプロジェクトを立ち上げました
そこからもっともっと大きなたくさんのことをやってみたいと思いまずは仲間を増やす
ことだと
イギリスロンドンで定例のネットワーキングイベント new idea クラブと
いうものを
主催で開催することにしました
そこで多くの企業がと知り合うことができ
沢山のプロジェクトの種が生まれました
その中で特に日本とイギリスをつなぐような形のプロジェクトが多数入ってきたことに
より日本の帰国も徐々に増えてきました
なので東京で活躍していたもうすでに機東京でもう既に活躍していた起業家との出会い
話をしさらにもっとプロジェクトのためを増やしていきました
web や sns でも発信もしていたので日本やイギリスだけに留まらず
アメリカやフランスだったり他の国の人からも連絡をもらい
skype などを通じてどんどん知り合いが増えてきました
その結果本当に世界中にいろんなプロジェクトの種を生むことができました
一人でかた非常張ってやっていた頃の身軽で多くのことに大きなことに挑戦することが
できるようになりました
しかし
長くは続きませんでした
沢山のプロジェクトを立ち上げ人を巻き込み
実行する
しかしお金を稼ぐことを忘れていたというわけではないんですがお金がまったく回らず
結局住んでいた家も出ないといけないといけないことになりました
当時持っていたビザも有効期限があと半年で切れる
そういう状況でした
成功した企業がのみに与えられる起業家ビザというものの取得をめざして
必死に向こうで活動していたのですがもうその可能性はほぼ絶望的で日本の帰国はほぼ
決定的になりました
しかし
最初の方でも述べましたが自分で何か大きなことを世界があっと驚くようなこと
まだ一度も行っていない
特にロンドンでまだその大きな爪痕を残すような活動
そんなことが全然できていない結局負けて日本に帰るそういう状況がさすがに許せませ
んでした
なのでこの状況で何かできないかと考える
考えるようになりました
そこで
まず今の現状を受け入れた上で自分に何ができるんだろうと考えました
僕は最初にも繰り返しいうのもちょっと恐縮なんですが僕は本当に何もできない人間
です
でも多くのプロジェクトに関われてこれたのは才能あふれる多くの起業家たちの友達が
僕の周りにだからだと思っています
なので
もっともっとコラボレーションの可能性を広げるためにこのホームレスという状況を
使ってもっと多くの人に出会うことができないか考えるようになりました
そこで約半年150日間ロンドンであいえな私生活を繰り替え
言えない生活を続けることではペニーのチェンジメーカーに遭うという企画ホーム列車
帳というものを立ち上げました
限られた時間でできるだけ多くの人たちにある
そういうシンプルな企画でした
もともと起業家層同じ業界にいる人達の知り合いは多く増えてはいたのですが
ホーム列車帳というものを通じて本当に異業種自分の分野ではない
面白い人たち才能あふれる人たちとの出会いもたくさん生まれました
憧れていたノルウェー人の映画監督
普通に生活していたら絶対に交わることはなかっただろう投資銀行のエリートフランス
人
とにかくバイタリティ溢れるメキシコ人起業家
本当にいろんな人に出会いました
憧れていたノルウェー人が監督とお茶をしたときは
本当に圧倒的なその発想力と形にも形に落としていくときのユニークな鑑定にはただ
たら感動しました
投資銀行で働くエリートフランス人の家に泊めてもらったときは彼はその夜
株取引で数億儲けていました
僕の想像絶するような世界で平然と勝負を仕掛けている彼の
精神力には本当に尊敬しました
そしてバイタリティ溢れるメキシコ人起業家は世界の教育システムを変えるんだとある
web サービスを立ち上げ
それを絶対に成功させるんだということで思いつく限りのアイデアを実行に移し
着実に1歩1歩を踏んでが一歩一歩前に進んでいました
彼の目の前にある度は必ずのノックをするその姿勢には本当に尊敬に値すると思いまし
た
今紹介した3人はただの一例にしかすぎません
このように本当にたくさんの人にたくさんの才能あふれる方達に
ホーム列車長という企画を通じてたくさんの人達には出会うことができました
でもそれは同時に
やっぱり自分って本当に何もできない人間なんだなというのも実感させられました
しかし彼らと日々いろんな話をするいろんな違った分野の話を僕の中にインプットする
ことで今まではなかったようなアイディアだったり今まで自分が考えつかなかったよう
な発想
そういうのも与えてもらいました
そこで同じ分野の人たちだけで関わるのではなくてもっと異業種の
もっと外の人たちと関わることで可能性というのはさらに大きくなるんだなっていうの
も実感しました
現在僕は今東京に戻っています今も昔とかが変わらずまだまだ一人で世界を変えるよう
なスーパー僕は持っていません
でも今と昔で大きく違うことがありますそれは
本当に世界を変えるようなスーパーパワーを持った友人知人が世界中にいることです
僕はこれから東京を拠点にして彼らとのつながりを生かし
ロンドンでの経験を生かしより多くのマジックをどんどんどんどん打っていこうと思っ
ています
実は今日のこのスライドも今東京で普段一緒に活動している仲間たちと
作りました
スーパーバーがない才能がないずっと入ってますが特に才能がないのは自分の考えて
いることを思っていることを言葉にしてこのように伝えることです
なのでてっぷ x の話をもらった時
嬉しかったんですけど
同時にヤバイ同省それが素直な気持ちでした
車
友達にテープエクスに出ることになったんだ
でをプレゼン下手だから手伝ってよって言うので
彼らも忙しい中彼ら彼女らも忙しい中
時間を抑えてくれて僕のプレゼンを見てくれて
忠誠をしてくれて行最初に挙げたスライドも友人が
悦也の仕事の中で
作ってくれました
言ってしまえば僕の着ている服も眼鏡も靴も
ホームレスがお金がなかった時に友達が3素晴らしいからって言ってくれたものだっ
たり
本当に僕はみんなの力があって今たぶんこの鉄平 x-このステージに立って皆さんに
メッセージを伝えています
最後になりますが
僕はこれからも昔と変わらず毎日人に会い話を聞き
つながる可能性を見出しながら一個一個アクションを起こしていきます
その中で世界があっと驚くようなライダーの挑戦もどんどんどんどんしていこうと思っ
ています
こんな僕でも出来たのでぜひ皆さんもコラボレーションを作るという生き方を通じて
もっと大胆にダイナミックに生きてみませんか
そんなに難しいことでありませんまずは人に会い話を聞きその違いを楽しむところから
始める
それだけでも
あなたのほしい未来をつくるマジックになるはずです
ご静聴ありがとうございました